I have been practicing medicine for almost 40 years now.
I've seen too many people
Relying on medication to lower blood sugar and blood pressure too much
almost led to a serious incident.
There was a lady
She is my diabetic patient.
Her husband couldn't sleep well every night.
I know that.
He also worries about his family.
Speaking of blood sugar
afraid it's too high and I'm afraid it's too low.
The person taking care of the child also couldn't sleep at night.
Her husband was worried that his blood sugar was too low
because of the medication and injections.
So he was incredibly nervous every night.
can't even sleep well at night.
He’s had a rough time
Yes, in this episode
I want to tell both healthy people and people with high blood sugar.
How to learn to stabilize your blood sugar
What's the best food to eat if you have high blood sugar?
Hu Naiwen is about to begin his lecture.
I am your old friend, Dr. Hu.
Come, let me tell you.
Unstable blood sugar
What impact will it have on you?
People with chronically high blood sugar are prone to
thirst, frequent urination, and fatigue.
Even blurred vision
If not properly controlled
Blood sugar will slowly
damage your blood vessels.
The risk of heart disease, stroke, and kidney
disease will increase in the future.
People with chronically low blood sugar
It is possible that
Dizziness, cold sweats, trembling hands
In the long run
It can also irritate the heart and blood vessels.
Risks of arrhythmia or myocardial infarction, etc.
They are all increasing
Moreover, immunity
It will get worse and worse.
Therefore, low blood sugar
does not necessarily mean you are healthy.
Too high or too low blood sugar
All of these could harm your heart.
It really can be fatal if it gets serious.
2 habits to break
Causes blood sugar spikes and fatty liver
To stabilize blood sugar
Stay away from diabetes complications
These two habits can easily
cause blood sugar to spike.
must quit or reduce
First habit
Drinking vegetable and fruit juices and eating a fruit feast
Do you think
drinking vegetable and fruit juices and eating lots of fruit makes you healthy?
wrong
There was once an old man in his eighties
He has had diabetes for 40 years.
Blood sugar is well controlled
One day, blood sugar suddenly spiked to 200 or 300.
It turns out it's
because he drinks such a big glass of vegetable and fruit juice every morning.
I know
Someone made a glass of vegetable and fruit juice
Vegetables and fruits used
More than a day's worth of food
Right, that would be too much
And there's too much
fructose in the food.
Fructose in fruit
It needs to be metabolized by the liver.
You eat too many fruits and vegetables
in a short period of time
The liver is actually overburdened
Excess fructose will be converted
into fat and stored in the liver.
Over time,
fatty liver may develop.
People with diabetes
What fruits to eat
So the sugar content won't be too high.
You can eat apples, blueberries, and guavas.
These three fruits
Low in sweetness and safe
Just don't eat too much.
It’s recommended
that you eat only one apple-sized portion a day
Eat two hours after a meal
Blood sugar will be much more stable
The second habit is eating dinner too late.
Do you often
ate dinner very late after working overtime.
After finishing eating,
lay down on the sofa and started scrolling through my phone.
Do not move your whole body
Only the fingers are moving.
The problem is the sugar and calories you consume.
The body doesn't have time to deplete it.
When sleeping
Insulin is busy lowering blood sugar
But the chase wasn't fast enough.
In the early morning
The liver will release
some sugar again
Blood sugar spikes upon waking up in the morning
It's hard to stay stable all day.
what to do
Try to do it before 7 PM.
After dinner
Allow the body enough time to digest
If you work overtime and eat very late
After eating
Get up and walk around for ten minutes.
Help lower blood sugar
So you won’t end up with love handles
What to do if blood sugar fluctuates?
Two acupoints to lower blood sugar and relieve constipation
People with high blood sugar
What are some methods
to quickly lower blood sugar?
Which acupoints can be pressed to lower blood sugar?
These two acupoints are incredibly useful.
Controlling blood sugar while protecting the spleen and stomach
Sān yīn jiāo , gōng sūn (transliteration)
Speaking of the Sān yīn jiāo(transliteration)acupoint
It can help you regulate your blood sugar
and all your endocrine system.
It also regulates three meridians: liver, spleen, and kidney.
Isn't that amazing?
Really?
These two acupoints are very useful!
It works great!
Sān yīn jiāo(transliteration)is located three inches above the tip of the medial malleolus.
About the width of four fingers
It means three cun, the Traditional Chinese Medicine unit of measurement.
You feel a hole.
It is calledSān yīn jiāo(transliteration)
I remember you said...
Pregnant women should not massage theSān yīn jiāo(transliteration)acupoint.
It is possible
There is a possibility of miscarriage.
You're so smart! Very smart indeed!
Pregnant women should be careful not to press this.
The second thing to control blood sugar is...
gōng sūn (transliteration)acupoint
gōng sūn (transliteration) acupoint can mobilize the spleen's energy,
especially
People prone to constipation and unstable blood sugar
They are all absolutely fantastic!
Many diabetics have a relatively weak spleen.
Traditional Chinese medicine says that the spleen is responsible for digestion and absorption.
If the spleen is not good
The food you eat
Uneven absorption
Blood sugar levels tend to fluctuate.
Constipation is also likely to occur in you.
Where is the gōng sūn (transliteration) acupoint?
Its location is in theJī gǔ(transliteration)
It is theJī gǔ(transliteration)of the metatarsal bone of the big toe.
Back of theJī gǔ(transliteration)
Then from the back of this place
Find a spot about the size of a thumb's inch further back;
this spot is called the gōng sūn (transliteration)acupoint.
You often get massages
The two acupointsSān yīn jiāoand gōng sūn (transliteration)
Make your blood sugar more stable
A healthier spleen and stomach
This will naturally improve constipation.
You pressed these two acupoints
What are your feelings?
You can leave me a message
Sugar-free drinks cause blood sugar to spike
1 tea lowers blood sugar
What tea can lower blood sugar?
There's a cup of tea that's quite nice, that is...
Burdock tea
In Traditional Chinese Medicine, burdock is believed to clear heat and detoxify
promote urination, and facilitate bowel movement.
Burdock will remove excess sugar and water
from the body.
Keeping blood vessels clean
makes them less prone to blockage.
This can thus lower blood sugar
and blood pressure
How to brew burdock tea
Burdock tea bags are available
in the market
Put the burdock tea bag
in a mug
Then pour in 250cc of hot water.
Let it steep for 5 minutes before drinking.
Very convenient
Awesome!
So, people with diabetes can have a cup.
Burdock tea can also lower blood pressure and blood sugar.
It smells very good.
It tastes pretty good too.
Who can't drink burdock tea?
Two types of people to avoid
First, pregnant women
Of course, it's women.
Second, common cold due to fēng hán (transliteration)
A cold like feeling cold
and having a slight cough
Do not drink
You might feel unwell after drinking it.
Many people now
They all love drinking bubble tea.
What drinks are suitable
for people with diabetes?
Any sugar-free beverage is fine.
Black tea, green tea, oolong tea
Sugar-free milk tea and regular milk are both fine, right?
However, this type of sugar-free beverage
Healthy people and diabetics should not drink it.
Sugar-free beverages containing sweeteners
According to research
People who consume large amounts of artificial sweeteners
The risk of developing diabetes
is significantly increased.
We healthy people
It's best to avoid sweeteners.
Yes, if diabetics really want to drink something sweet...
suggest you buy sugar-free drinks
to take home.
Adding your honey
is better than adding sugar
or fructose from outside.
Blood sugar does not spike after meals
Yam protects blood vessels and lowers blood pressure, blood sugar, and cholesterol.
people whose post-meal blood sugar doesn’t come down
I highly recommend you eat yams.
Once, a friend of my friend
Say going for a health checkup
blood sugar is a little high.
asked my friend.
I have high blood sugar.
Is there any way?
can lower my blood sugar
without taking blood sugar-lowering medication.
Do you have any methods?
My friend studies medicine.
He told him it was very simple.
You can steam the yam and eat it.
a daily intake of one, two,
or three Liǎng (transliteration)
As a result, blood sugar stabilized after a few days
After another blood sugar test, it returned to normal
It is evident
that yam does more than just lower blood sugar
It really can help
stabilize blood sugar
Isn't yam a starch?
Can people with high blood sugar eat this?
Good question
The key point is the yam.
Sticky and slippery
mucoprotein
It acts like a natural protective film.
Food that can encapsulate the intestines
Let the sugar be released slowly.
To avoid a spike in blood sugar after meals
Even better
Yam can cleanse blood vessels
Prevent fat accumulation
Make cardiovascular system healthier
At the same time, it nourishes the kidneys and stabilizes blood sugar.
It is a fantastic food for lowering blood pressure, blood sugar, and cholesterol.
Beautiful wife
What's the best way to eat yam?
I know
Steam or boil the yam.
They're all delicious!
Is the yam, millet, and lean pork porridge you cooked...?
Yes, yam, millet, and lean pork porridge
There's also yam and pork rib soup.
They're all delicious!
Both blood sugar and blood pressure are taken care of.
Right?
yes
It's also good for people with high blood pressure, high cholesterol, and high blood sugar
to eat here
Cook into sì shén tāng (transliteration)
How do you like to cook yams?
Leave us a message
A renowned chef has been using one vegetable to make soup
that has helped stabilize blood sugar levels for nearly 50 years.
Patients with high blood sugar or diabetes
Don't rely solely on salt and soy sauce when stir-frying.
Switch to blood sugar-controlling vegetables
Like onions and garlic
Not only is it very fragrant
It can also lower blood sugar
It's delicious even with less salt.
Can onions lower blood sugar?
Can
Quercetin in onions
It not only slows down the absorption of sugar.
It also protects blood vessels
Disciple of the Imperial Cook of Japan
窪田好直
in his forties
to develop diabetes
The doctor recommended that he take insulin.
He hopes to be able to live without relying on medication.
drink own homemade onion soup every day.
Fasting blood sugar
dropped from 200 to 130
And he didn't take a single pill.
It has been almost fifty years
Did you know?
This 窪田好直
He is now over 90 years old.
He's still the head chef at the restaurant.
Full of energy!
Wow, that's amazing!
How do you make onion soup?
I've put the quantities and instructions here.
You can try it out by taking a screenshot.
1 kg of onions, approximately 4
15g of kelp shreds
1/2 clove of garlic
50g of bacon
1 and 2/3 teaspoons of white soy sauce
3/4 teaspoon soy sauce
2/3 teaspoon of vinegar
A pinch of pepper
1200cc of water
How do eat garlic?
Can control blood sugar
Clinical evidence
You can eat it every day
Two grams of fresh garlic
About the amount of one clove
The amount of one garlic bulb
Blood sugar can be stabilized over several weeks
The allicin in this garlic
can promote insulin secretion
Carry blood sugar into cells
Dear fans
We have launched the membership channel.
If you agree with my promotion of Traditional Chinese Medicine
The concept of taking care of one's own health
Small monthly donations are welcome.
It only costs the price of two cups of coffee!
Or become a VIP sponsor
With you by my side
Only then can we go further
Thank you so much!